because this generation hasn't faced  rule adversity and all the adversity  they face is on social media so for  example like you said your parents left  their country and came here and made it  work your marriage you have to make it  work you have to put in the  efforts  I think there's got to be someone else  like missing from the story it's  literally okay I'm not denying I'm  trying to make the marriage work right  it's I can't it takes two to tangle  right again he it might come to a point  in his life that he realizes actually  Soraya is there regardless whether he's  a millionaire or zilch and then he might  be like actually I can see it yeah but  it's very hard especially the area he  was brought up in he was around a lot of  superficial people I grew up in Hackney  I came from like Eddie poverty whatever  like my family came here with nothing I  grew up with that that's my reality I'm  not I don't care about designer Goods I  don't care about materialistic things